j'ai chili abandonne et j'ai 19 ans je
commençais à me droguer en octobre 68
coups à l'interné
il n'y avait pas que la mer le soleil et
les chansons sur la côte d'azur cet été
il y avait aussi la drogue
martin 17 ans est morte à bandol
jean-claude la ciotat à marseille les
policiers ont saisi 590 kg d'opium et
arrêter les trafiquants
ce redoutable fléau qui nous vient de
l'étranger choisi ses victimes dans tous
les milieux
martin vivait avec sa mère et son
grand-père dans cette jolie ville à
ses camarades de jeu aujourd'hui en
prison sont issus de familles modestes
plusieurs d'entre eux habitaient ces hlm
mais la vie continue à bandol et la
jeunesse essaie d'oublier le drame
qu'elle vient de vivre
ces garçons et ces filles ont presque
tous connus martin est logé le jeune
dogue est qu'il y avait fait la piqûre
mortelle
[Musique]
certains d'entre eux avaient assisté à
la réunion se pressent dans le terrain
vague derrière ce cimetière c'est ici
avec les morts comme seuls témoins
qu'ils essayaient le haschich puis
l'héroïne
jean-jacques leurs amis raconte comment
tout cela avait commencé d'abord s'est
passé l'été il y avait des beatniks et
des jeunes qui descendent et il parlait
le haschich de marijuana moi je le sais
pas tous sachent pas pourquoi ça n'était
jamais venu à l'esprit même de passer à
me droguer et un jour un jeune homme a
proposé un garçon emménage à peu près
tient un couteau ça s'est su bien tu
verras c'est pas dangereux c'est pas
toxique que tu peux tu d'un point qu'une
cyrus quart-arrière tout j'ai goûté ça
m'a plu bien sûr j'étais plus du tout
moi fins je voyais des images sur le
sentiment d'être quelqu'un d'autre quoi
oui peut-être
plus fort que que ça et enfin le hachis
c'est pas du tout pareil que l'héroïne
toute façon les russes à l'héroïne ça
vous sort de la personnalité on sent là
avec l'héroïne se sent vraiment plus
fort que vous ressentez faible les gens
qui vous oui je me sens assez fun oui
parce que je suis aucun but vous avez
l'impression d'être inutile quoi je n'ai
pas
l'impression de servir à rien voilà je
suis toujours à tf1 j'ai raté mes études
et j'ai
fais un métier qui
pouvait m'intéresser ça n'a pas marché
non plus finalement j'ai travaillé
[Musique]
parce que j'étais obligé de travailler
quoi et pourquoi avez-vous la télé vous
étiez
ça c'est parce que ça me faisait pas que
je n'aimais pas les jeux mais pas
travailler beaucoup d'écoles quoi depuis
la ville était maman je suis
la fille blanche
des guerres de partout
je parle
des crises des grèves des
manifestations et
puis je pars je suis pas heureux quoi
je n'en ai que devenir l'héroïne bella
l'héroïne c'est venu comme comme le
haschich pas joué en maliki y'a pas et
pas de haschich si tu veux prendre des
ruines tu leur as aussi bon
alors je n'ai jamais j'ai goûté coiffer
d'abord je mangeais prise est sûr
c'est un peu comme le haschich sur ce
sens là mais sauf qu'on voit pas on n'a
pas de vision c'est pas si nos gènes
communs comme le haschich la mjc
psychique quoi puis on a
un flash quand même un peu c'est un
flash qui durent pas prêt et 10 minutes
là ça se passe dans le cerveau alors on
est un peu facile quoi puis
un point c'est physique surtout on march
s
en aperçoit pas quoi on peut on peut
briser puis là la seule barre où
s'asseoir
intéresse un café à faire mais pour tous
les chantiers
qui vous dit bonjour qui vous
connaissent s'aperçoit pas du tout comme
ça devant lui expliquez-moi comment
est-ce qu'on se procure cette langue ça
c'est pas c'est pas difficile comment
quand c'est la portée de tout le monde
vous allez là
dans une rue vous savez kana vous savez
qu'à des vendeurs et vous ôtera pauvres
eux
sont aussi moins coûteux jeunes avec les
cheveux un petit peu lents comme moi
vous rabattre le suit quand ils
mettraient mais sans vous
de ça c'est bon c'est à marseille et à
marseillan finale à toutes les villes
ça fonctionne non c'est un bon bah oui
très
il ya beaucoup de jeunes qui se rendent
aussi bandol mais là quelques-uns
sont tout simplement à tous n'ont pas
tous
quoi est ce qu'on a toujours envie de
continuer j'ai pas envie de continuer
parce que parce que c'est bien parce que
ça nous plaît on se dit oh on ne
touchera pas c'est pas possible c'est du
bluff a vu d'abord il toxiques et qu'est
ce que ça veut dire qu elle a toujours
un avis mais moi je sais que si je veux
m'arrêter je pourrais m'arrêter bien
josette intoxiqué c'est fini m'a plu
arrêté pour avoir un toubib ou faire
comme moi le dire mais par un et nous
avons l'hôpital pour qu'il essaie de le
faire entrer dans la tête que j'ai autre
chose à ma vie quoi vous avez dit à vos
parents vous même oui moi j'ai dit à mes
parents parce que je voulais que ça les
pages j'avais envie je voulais m'arrêter
je suis intelligent et je pouvais pas
c'est atrocement
ces deux jours je n'avais plus je me
sentais fatigué physiquement et
moralement je sentais que je rêve de me
tuer je vais me suicider
la mort de martin a suscité une vive
émotion parmi la population
certains accusent le pharmacien parce
qu'il a vendu des seringues aux
adolescents d'autres accusent le maire
ou les parents
vous avez vendu beaucoup de seringue aux
jeunes dernièrement au début de l'année
on en venait pas mal aux gens à l'un des
jeunes oui et d'ailleurs c'est ce qui
nous a vraiment
permis de mentionner social à police
l'épi de de rectifier la vente
courante à des jeunes
mais en ce moment est ce que c'est
encore autorisée est ce que des jeunes
peuvent venir et acheter des seringues
librement les jeunes peuvent venir mais
vous refusant la vente étant donné
ce qu'on a devant lui et
monsieur françois fabre maire de bandol
avait vu grandir toute la jeunesse de sa
ville
je passe le sont des enfants qui ont été
mal conseillés qui ont eu de mauvaises
fréquentations avec eux à mon avis on
peut récupérer
oui absolument mais surtout dès que j'ai
su quelque chose chez prévenez la police
mais la police je crois mon avis a été
dépassé par les événements parce qu'elle
ne s'attendait pas à des moments aussi
rapide aussi fatale pour cette fausse
que ce qui se produit
mais en toute conscience depuis
plusieurs mois j'avais prévenu la police
je n'avais pas manqué de le rabaisser
tous les éléments leur communiquer tous
les éléments que j'avais en ma
possession
les parents des garçons et des filles
aujourd'hui en prison sans bouleverser
ils ne comprennent pas
aux ordures ménagères mais travailler
bien il n'y avait pas un garçon très
très gentil très très chouette vous êtes
un père sévère aux gentils
sévir cv on est plus ou moins même veine
on n'est pas des tortionnaires on ne
sommes pas des tensions mais on essaie
de
les rendre heureux le plus possible
vous êtes aperçu qui se droguait à
jamais de la vie celui-ci se brouillent
commune en effet propos proférés 40 km
par jour
en soulevant des poubelles c'est pas
possible
moi j'ai jamais vu un breguet mois
qu'ils fassent un travail manuel
commence à moi j'ai jamais vu leur
contrat initial qui rit j'ai jamais vu
mais heureusement jamais faire l'amour
en moi ni à s'asseoir sur une échelle
plus bouger ça j'ai jamais vue en prison
vous l'avez vu oui je les ai vus en
prison malheureusement
comme un héros malheureux parce que
cette emprise encore du lait m si
vraiment ils sont ici s'ils sont
vraiment un toxique y est
si ceux ci sont vraiment atteint cuisson
intoxiqué ici d'un hôpital comme dans
les mers de la pizza un petit tapis
tapisseries que c'est pas dans les
prisons passé dans les prisons ils sont
mélangés que pierre et paul alors après
qu'un yvonne sortir ils sont encore bien
plus dur que quelqu'un dise on rentrait
pas cela si c'est plus un remède ça
c'est la faute à qui est ce que c'est la
faute des pateras jamais ravi la faute
des parents moi je vous dis le miel à
21,6 à wenchang herman cain d'ossau il
faut à minuit des eaux viens viens me
toucher la poitrine quand tu rentres
tout de même moins avantagées t il
j'avais un fusil à la main j'étais au
drapeau a été sous les drapeaux alors je
ne vois pas qu'à 20 ans on dit aux
garçons bien me toucher la poitrine pour
air pur pour pouvoir citer bien rentrer
un v6 et l'indicible ça il aurait eu 15
là d'accord mais à 20 ans je ne vois pas
aussi qu'on peut interdire un garçon de
rentrer après le spectacle 00h30
minéraux qui est responsable
la responsabilité la responsabilité
incombe plutôt le les pouvoirs publics
parce qu'un principe c'est eux les
responsables
c'est le service d'ordre dans ses
services
surveillance
ce sont les responsables
et d'autant plus qu' il le savait qu'ils
auraient pu prévenir certains il aurait
pu prévenir certains noms de certaines
par an
si vraiment il était au courant de cette
histoire là qu'on puisse et un fils il
n'y a pas plus gentil n'y pas plus calme
et on me les gens me disent tu
t'apercevras de rien absolument de rien
nous avons eu des échos d'abord il
fréquente et une bande qui ne nous
plaisait pas nous avons fait des pieds
et des mains pour l'en sortir de là il
en était un peu détaché voilà trois
semaines qui ne les fréquente et plus
qui ne sortaient plus ils étaient
surveillés pas à pas maintenant quand il
faisait sa distribution le télégramme
nous pouvions pas y être derrière
constamment
il est dans la validité graphiste à la
poste il en a pas du tout le jour quoi
il fait la distribution télégramme eh
bien vous savez était vendeur c'est
grand alors s'il a vraiment il avait
envie de le faire rentrer deux
télégrammes vous savez il n'y a pas de
faux pas unir pour faire ça je l'avais
emmener un docteur pour qu'ils lui
donnent de quoi le calme et si vraiment
il en avait besoin ma foi il m'avait dit
vous savez il n'a pas le physique dans
tout ça donnait lui m'avait donné des
ampoules et des comprimés qui prenait
régulièrement
donc nous n'avions pas ok nous n'avions
pas nous en l'armé au poing de jeu c'est
pas à moi de les retenir ligne porter
plaine mais quoi qu'il ya des mères de
famille qui ont porté plainte ça n'a
rien ça n'a rien déclenché
oui j'ai pu le voir
à des chantiers parce qu'ils en gros
sous silence ou si tu dois passer son
examen le 21 septembre il en bien perdre
pour pouvoir passer voilà le mal est
réparé si si elle ne justice j'estime
que c'est et on devrait lui autorisé au
moins à le faire parce que ça alors là
ça lui coûte sa vie entière puis c'est
tout quand même pas comparer à des
criminels et des voleurs ils ont failli
jouer avec leur santé c'est tout mais
les responsables les responsables
j'estime que la police il ya deux ans
qui le savent ils auraient pu mettre
arrestation avant ne pas attendre qu'il
est mort voilà la police a bon dos vous
le savez que je dois vous dire que dans
les affaires que je n'ai pas traiter
personnellement mais qui ont été dressés
traités par le services de monsieur
denis mon collègue de marseille il est
certain que lorsque la police a été
informée immédiatement les
fonctionnaires ont procédé en qu'est ce
qu'il y a ceux qui semblent drôle et
excuse qui semble particulier à la
population puisque vous parlez de
population c'est ce laps de temps qu'ils
ont mis pour appréhender ou identifier
les individus mais vous savez que dans
des affaires comme ça les enquêtes ne
sont pas faciles il faut enquêter il
faut recréer des renseignements portant
des témoins il faut que le climat se
prête également l enquête et je vous
assure qu'à marseille on a tout fait
tout pour que cette affaire sorte et le
plus rapidement possible
si vous étiez en présence d'une femme
qui vous dirait monsieur le commissaire
monfils n'a pas volé une actuelle est en
prison il a un examen à passer le 25 de
ce mois ci il ne peut pas le passé son
avenir sera compromis que lui diriez
vous à cette femme eh bien je lui dirai
que d'abord at elle elle même conscience
du problème qui se pose at elle eu
l'autorité nécessaire sur son enfant
pour l'empêcher de se droguer s'était
aperçue que son enfance orthez et l
aperçu qu'il fréquentait des garçons qui
eux mêmes se droguer s'est elle
inquiétée lorsque le garçon entre à 5
heures du matin dans un état qui n'était
peut-être pas normal voilà ce que je lui
dirai maintenant il est évident que
c'est très gênant pour un jeune de ne
pouvoir passer un examen mais lui même
il ya t'il penser à l'examen qu'ils
devaient passer d'après vous qui est
responsable eh bien je crois
personnellement que la responsabilité
incombe en grande partie aux parts il y
a comme aux états unis où je suis allé
il ya quelques temps il y a un manque
d'autorité certaine d'autre part je
crois que l'information n'est pas
suffisamment n'est pas suffisamment
grande en france et je pense que ça va
être
dans très peu de temps nous allons
aborder le problème de l'information
nous avons actuellement monsieur puise
actuellement monsieur le ministre
intérieur vient de prendre des mesures
très particulière et très importante en
ce qui concerne la répression du trafic
et la consommation de la drogue des
nouvelles équipes sont mises en place
les surveillances les contrôles les
descentes vont amplifier sur le
territoire français et mon dieu je pense
que ces mesures seront très bonne et que
nous aurons rapidement de très bons
résultats des résultats tangibles qui
nous permettra qui nous permettront
d'enrayer cette cette vague cette petite
vague qui semblait vous voir déferler
sur la france à l'origine vous savez que
la france était un lieu de transit pour
les trafiquants de stupéfiants trafic
tout à fait particulier dont je m'occupe
avec marseille au à la au sein de
l'office central mais il est évident que
depuis quelques temps on a l'impression
qu'elle devient un pays de consommation
mais consommation disons surtout sur le
cannabis c'est d'être le chanvre indien
la marijuana le kif et c'est en ce qui
concerne une ruine il ya très peu de
consommateurs d'héroïne d'ailleurs je
dois vous dire la chose suivante c'est
que les étrangers les jeunes étrangers
représentent environ dans les affaires
que nous traitons 50% des intoxiqués
interpellé et appelant dé c'est vous
dire que tout même la jeunesse française
est bien plus celle qu'on veut le dire
s'il savait que cette piqûre leur fera
connaître tôt ou tard des souffrances
effroyable le fret il
quel est le pourcentage des rechutes
90% actuellement 90% de rechute nous
pouvons dire que vous dire ils sont 10%
définitive ces biens supposés vous qui
êtes là devant moi normal je vous fait
pendant 15 jours ou trois semaines des
piqûres d'héroïne dans trois semaines
vous n'êtes plus la même femme
qu'aujourd'hui et vous allez demandez
vous à les supplier pour qu'on continue
ce traitement et c'est ça qui est le
drame et ça vous met alors dans un état
second c'était un second va vous
conduire à quoi va vous conduire à la
délinquance à du vagabondage tout ce
qu'il faut avoir la drogue et puis
progressivement progressivement ça va
aller vers ce que nous appelons la
décompensation psychique bien sûr ça
n'est pas immédiate 7 des compensations
mais alors c'est l'état de psychose et
tous les drogués savent très bien ils
ont vu leurs camarades ils les décrivent
ces les skyzos les paranos qu'est ce que
ça veut dire ce sont des gens qui
actuellement ont détruit leur
structuration cérébrale par l' usage de
la drogue et c'est ça qui est absolument
dramatique
car ils seront plus jamais des états
normaux des gens normaux oui y
reviendrons très difficilement à l'état
normal alors que faire mais il ya tout
un programme d'abord et ça c'est
l'action administrative
il faut
lutter contre la distribution des
drogues c'est le travail de la
commission des stupéfiants le ministre
de la santé publique et la sécurité
sociale en est conscient la commission
qui a déjà fait beaucoup de travail va
se remettre à la tâche pour mieux
spécifier les instructions à donner à
tout ça c'est digne des aspects
administratifs et puis il faut que nous
renforcions de la thérapeutique comme je
voulais dit tout à l'heure nous avons du
mal à inclure le traitement de ces
drogués dans notre politique d'hygiène
mentale car il pose des problèmes
particuliers au personnel ne où nos
services sociaux sont actuellement peu
familiarisé il faut des familiariser
davantage parce que ce sont des malades
ont besoin d'être encadrés qui ont
besoin d'être est inscrit dans la
société et dès maintenant nous allons
mettre au point des centres plus
spécialisé à paris à lyon à marseille
par tous est nécessaire
pour que cette action thérapeutique
puisse être mené avec la plus grande
énergie et puis il n'y a pas d'action
thérapeutique et à l'action préventive
il faut que tout le monde comprenne
aussi bien les parents la société que
nous c'est notre responsabilité à chacun
et dans le domaine qui est plus celui de
mon ministère c'est à nos médecins
scolaires car vous savez que c'est des
cherry jeunes actuellement ça commence
et à partir de 15 ans vous voyez des
gens qui fument le chanvre c'est dans
ces milieux scolaires universitaires
jeunes que nous avons de grands dégâts
et bien c'est au médecin santé scolaire
c'est à l'assistante sociale de se
familiariser avec ce problème est
d'aider ces jeunes à se réinsérer dans
la société
ça c'est l'action que nous voulons mener
et je crois que nous gagnons c'est le
mal de la civilisation actuelle je pense
que c'est un des mots de la civilisation
indienne des adolescents insouciants
joue au ballon devant le mur de la
prison dans laquelle sont enfermés
d'autres adolescents mais avant d'être
là n'était-il pas déjà dans une prison
plus impitoyable encore la drogue
[Musique]